[Music]
in it was me news at me
it means submitted by shabang shabang
he's my friend
a man faked his own murder using a gun
and a weather balloon what is this the
[ __ ] Balloon Boy [ __ ] what's a
weather balloon yeah what is that it's
like the things that they used to blame
UFOs on
they're like Silver Bullet do you
remember loon boy no what is that back
in like early 2000 sweet Bubble Boy no
no that there was like this family was
like oh my god my son stuck in the jaw
yeah yeah balloon but he was actually
hiding in the Attic the whole time they
were doing it and everyone was like the
news followed it they they had to like
safely get this balloon down and cuz
they said that the boy was in there and
then later on they did an interview and
then there the the lady interviewed them
there and they asked the boy like why'd
you do that and then the kid goes oh
because mom and dad told us to do it for
TV the parents were like oh I'm in
trouble they got in trouble for that
[ __ ] they had to pay for like all the
resources that was used yeah hmm they
did it for attention oh I was thinking
Bubble Boy with Jake Gyllenhaal cuz
that's for my movies dawg yeah dang yeah
but uh so this guy here his name was
Ellen he apparently so he's 71 years old
when he was found dead ain't back in
January he apparently bought two weather
balloons and he attached a string to a
gun of one of them and he committed
suicide to vo weather balloon cuz you
wanted it to make it look like it was a
murder so apparently he had been
planning this because investigators said
that they found Google searches dating
back all the way to 2009 on how to
commit suicide by gun or hanging or
drugs and poison
and and so he was also and so he was
also searching the internet for
questions on how cuz he had several life
insurance policy was taken out on him so
he wanted to see if these policies would
pay out for suicides or if he had to be
murdered or like which way he had to die
so the cops when they first found him it
was a complete mystery because they
didn't have a murder weapon like they
found like this weird trail of blood and
like they it was just really weird but
then they finally figured out that he
did all this by a weather balloon damn
and he was still alive no he's you guys
she committed suicide I still don't know
what a whether things are something fake
isn't his day he faked the murder google
weather balloon I don't even know what
that is really big balloon Oh because
life policies it doesn't count if you
kill yourself so he had to fake the
murder I see okay got it so he wanted to
take care of his family or something
yeah I mean he did have family so this
is an example of a weather balloon
it's basically weather balloons are used
to like for to check like forecast shoot
in whatever okay cool I got it now
that's all I wanted to know I still
don't know what that is over you wanted
to see it yeah well a lot of these are
great white ones
there's some one nice silver big ones
it's just it's just to indicate like
it's gonna be this it's gonna be there
it goes up super high and does I don't
know where it does up there wild so he
did that to kill himself
yeah how'd it work how do you rig this
yeah I guess I guess they're right now
cuz I had the same ended well I'm glad I
asked them to yes I'm glad you did to
Bart this is what it looks like oh cool
what a cool picture I want to be in
there so what does it do it just goes up
there and gets the weather no like a lot
of photographers use this or people that
want to study like the atmosphere and
[ __ ] wouldn't they attach it to the
balloon and send it up there basically
it pops cuz it obviously can't survive
in space retrieve the information from
wherever it dropped super cool yeah
while and I don't know anything about
this yeah I think like before GPS I
wonder how the [ __ ] people knew where it
was
if it landed somewhere yeah didn't
redbull do a campaign where they like
got I was in a weather balloon or on
with a GoPro and they try to get the
redbull as close to the ozone layer as
possible or to like outer space
basically
maybe Oh fun do you like that was a
campaign I can't remember I remember Red
Bull was involved with the guy yeah
wait didn't he skydive from the
atmosphere without a parachute okay
maybe that was it you did okay but there
is they do do that do they jump out with
no parachute to that's something else I
think he was aiming for a low shoot
landing whatever it's a pulling as late
as poss
yeah but and then is there a motive to
why he wanted to commit suicide and make
it seem like it was a murder the money
right that's the only life insurance how
did he break this to work and understand
so he had a gun attached to a weather
balloon with a string maybe the stream
was on the trigger no if the weather
balloon goes up at home yes and so you
just put his head in it
it takes the balloon takes the gun away
oh wow Wow but not smart enough cozy
they figured it out yeah right exactly
what how they figure it out Google
searches and then they did find the how
to kill self with weather balloon and
take go no crazy
there's a life insurance cover this and
then Amazon weather balloon the only the
only thing that they found near hint
near his body was a small pair of silver
scissors to cut the stream so if you do
kill yourself then you can't get life
insurance like even if you're [ __ ]
sick as hell and you just want to go but
they're like now Betty you got to stay
alive that's how it works huh damn so
how do you like leave with the bang
while you give something to your family
I got with the bang literally did the
family get the life insurance I don't
know maybe that dad they got it and then
now it's been ruled a suicide so
probably
yeah yeah I remember I'm reading this
one website this guy who decided to kill
himself and he made a website I'm like
why who I am Baba and it literally was
I'm not crazy I'm just I've lived long
enough and I can I just want to go out
in my own way
like I'm not sad there was this couple
that did that they like agreed that once
their memory started going or like they
couldn't you know they were really
really smart and they loved like doing
puzzles together and challenges and
stuff you know like they agreed that
like when one starts to go they would
like joint suicide together
and they just went to a tent one day or
they left they told the kids that they
were like gold keV I like they plan it
they like if we're gonna do it October
bla bla bla and and then they just went
into a tent in their backyard and they
pulled it kiddo we're gonna kill them
yeah yeah what day they were gonna do is
say their goodbyes and stuff and and all
that but they just like didn't want to
ever be a burden
crazy or yeah I thought wow I like that
that's my count wait till I'm like
unapologetically crazy so my mom like
she's she's like super devout Buddhist
and she feels like she's done with what
she ever just to do in this world so
she's trying to go to there's like this
mountain in China or like I guess a lot
of people that are trying to leave the
reincarnation cycle and he gone you pray
for 30 days or something and you're
supposed to your soul leaves her body so
that's what my mom whoa your mom's like
I want to die I don't want to yeah but I
don't think that she's really gonna
carry it out could carry it outside
she's a [ __ ] I don't know like I think
that's not really part of her radar like
her radar was like helping send her
parents to her heaven or whatever and
she did a really good job of that of
both spending like I think the last
three or four years in Taiwan and
praying and servicing my grandpa my
grandma and then she likes Tiger but I
don't think she has like a that's not
really her purpose I feel like oh that's
so interesting and that's something that
I've already like knew since I was a kid
so I just lived with this I'm okay my
mom wants to [ __ ] do some suicide
chick go ahead strange yeah
she wants to become incense smoke in the
clouds yeah special dance and the men in
the meantime
that's so obvious fire you know she's
not like suicidal sad
yeah like my times up yeah my duties are
done yeah my duties are done
time to go [ __ ] no do you feel about
that I've just known since I was a kid
that my mom's a crazy-ass [ __ ] so it's
just whatever the [ __ ] she wants it's
like if that's what you want
go ahead if you want to stick around be
a grandma go ahead I said I got you it
affect you
I don't know affect me any other like
positively or negatively cuz I've
already like had closure before it
happened you know it's almost like
someone telling you like hey I'm gonna
go leave or whatever not more have been
cool at that since he already accepted
you then if she was just like she danced
her little heart off she's like I've
never felt more alive and then she
starts pursuing like professional
dancing she's like Vivian in that one
episode of Fresh Prince what aunt Vivian
at one episode of fresh crazy hot like
at first she's all shy cuz everyone's
all hot and young this she walks where
she goes nope I love that episode SAS
that's gonna be your mom but in China
Taiwan yeah my grandma every year would
be like I want to die I'm ready to die
I'd like my Filipino grandma because my
grandpa died like thirty years or twenty
years ago and they were really in love
like that was her best friend and like
she was never moved on and ever like
remarried or anything and she would
always every time I saw her I should be
like I want to see papa I'm done oh no
gran we have to make to my wedding so
like we'd have like benchmarks of like
no you gotta make it to this he's like
she's like I don't know this is my last
one
she's like Nikki you coming over for
Christmas cuz this might be my last
Christmas yeah
Wow in Carson or in Seal Beach now but
um but yeah who's still alive and kick'n
huh
she's still alive and kicking oh yeah
she's like got so much energy she's
super sharp yeah you know and then so
recently like last October she had her
birthday in Vegas and she had so much
fun that she's like I'm gonna be around
for many years like the first time in
like ten years you say noon my dad has a
life insurance he's like I have to die
before 60 so that you guys can get my
money no it has to be before 16 like no
it doesn't shut out my change it seems
parents are in their 60s already right
my dad just hit 50 dude jaws hit 50 and
like chill for a second when you
couldn't extend it a little bit my dad's
like that too weird like like where he
they're so like logical about it they're
like you need an X amount of money if I
die before this time he's still trying
to like everything every time I come
visit he's like a thousand dollars I'm
like no dad stop it you have to hide it
back in his room before I leave like
it's a back and forth always you try to
take care that's nice I would have every
time and I had to be hide it back in his
room or else I'll like I'll later hide
his room or I'll give him even more
money back I'm like here you go boo boo
what if he never even intended to give
it to you because he knows you're gonna
give it back he's like yeah serial
number it's gonna be the same same he's
so cute like dad stop I'm fine no no no
no you and my daughter here take this
take this
he always pulls it out of like a random
pocket it's like cash or Jessa's cash
and like that side pocket like the last
one owes his chest pocket hims like that
stop it it swallowed an abalone
thousand dollar yeah so cute he's
adorable I love my papa
[Music]
[Music]